[Musique]
et des amis et une vraie sorcière
j'espère oui faudrait seulement que
j'arrive à temps et l'examen d'admission
est l'académie supérieure de sorcellerie
et nicole pour future sorcière la magie
existe vraiment si vous faut des preuves
je me ferai un plaisir de vous
transformer en citrouille cyril
transformés en cochons des sorcières
transformé en grenouille
tous ces incidents ne sont le fait que
d'une seule élève
amandine bas la bulle la famille
d'amandine n'est peut-être pas magique
mais elle émet qui entraient dans cette
école par sa propre volonté
la magie entre de mauvaises mains peut
être extrêmement dangereux hiver
socrates qui perd tout le temps si le
film arrivera rien si cette jeune fille
n'est pas vrai que nous serons condamnés
à devoir l'a renvoyé julia quand on est
au plus bas de ces le moment jamais de
prouver à ses détracteurs qu'ils ont
tort cette fois je pense que je vais
surprendre pas mal de monde
[Musique]